what's up my fellow geeks zacky here
with geek culture bringing you another
fantastic video today we will be talking
about the second generation lg pericare
wearable air purifier but it's a lot of
words anyway this smart face mask is
loaded with two h13 heap of filters
along with some unique tech features but
with that being said if you have not
seen its first generation bigger brother
in detail well all you need to do is
click that card above
as we said before the mast is fitted
with two h13 heaper filters and the lg
dual fans that control airflow
automatically by sensing the user's
breathing patterns to make breathing
easier and more natural now it's quite
amazing how it actually works it
actually senses your breathing so when
you breathe in the fans kind of
wizzle on visual is that the word it
doesn't give you that like the hot air
that is encapsulated when you wear a
normal like cloth mask or a disposable
mask the dual fence here along with that
technology to sense
that that breathing pattern
really really helps
so it kind of gives you a dual purpose
here it supplies that filtered air and
on top of that it keeps your face in
that sense cool
now to break down the understanding of
why it's called the lg piracy wearable
air purifier is because they took the
same concept from their air purifier
lineup and shrunk down that concept
to more face friendly portable version
for your face now lg has also made this
mask as we said before much slimmer and
much lighter than the first generation
weighing at 94 grams as compared to the
first gen weighing at 126 grams some may
argue that it is still slightly bigger
than a regular disposable mask but if
you really think about it in terms of
the size
it's pretty much
the same
it's just a lot thicker
i say thicker it's like t-sh icc
suck my tech wear fans you guys will
love this
and many of you will probably be asking
oh my god zacky is this like
you know safe to use you know made out
of plastic and you know is this safe
with all the chemicals and stuff like
that well lg has
made the effort to make most of its
components
medical grade such as this face guard
now this phase guard is made of medical
grade silicone and what it does is that
it ensures that you have a nice tight
fit
around the nose and chin area while
still giving that ventilation with these
little holes over here
now on top of that you have the inner
cover sleeve which kind of acts as a
i would say helps with the moisture
levels you know when you talk when you
breathe so this helps out a lot and
doesn't stain
this inner part with saliva as they call
it
now
of course you also have the hepa filters
two of them
in fact
the face guard inner sleeve and the
hipaa filters
of course the ear straps are replaceable
so you can keep it all clean and
hygienic
and i said that clean with a lot of spit
so
now to turn the mask on all you need to
do is just press and hold the single
button over here which is just next to
the usbc port and the fans will start
turning on now there are three fan
speeds one beep
for the lowest
two beeps for medium and three beats for
high now all of these depends on what
you're doing if you're walking breast
walking jogging then this will help you
supply
more air
as they breathe now charging is as
simple as it gets you have a usbc
charging port over here now it doesn't
come with its own charging adapter but
it does come with a usb a to usb c cable
with that said any available usb port
should work battery life is also
extended thanks to its 1000 milliamp
hour battery it lasts for 8 to 10 hours
depending on your usage of the fan
speeds and it's gonna vary a little more
when you're gonna use its voice on
feature yes that's right lg has added a
built-in microphone and speaker onto the
second generation face mask now this
helps to project your voice more clearly
because we know with the first
generation or in fact any other
disposable mask you end up sounding like
bane
brother can you hear me
not that great isn't it
and i can see why many consumers eagerly
wanting the first generation lost their
interest or just simply turn their heads
away no longer
ah
geek culture will be right back after
these messages
[Music]
this video is brought to you by logitech
here at geek culture gaming is a way of
life and we always enjoy dishing out
headshots with the logitech g pro x
super light mouse the lightweight
wireless mouse combines excellent
performance with a classy no-frills look
designed with pros and engineer to win
it offers crisp and responsive clicks
the smooth operator even allows you to
swap out the magnetic dongle storage
compartment for greater gliding ease
check out all of its other features over
at logitechg.com
let's give the second generation
wearable air purifier a shot
now
obviously
it's a lot less muffled i assume we have
not activated voice on technology yet
all i need to do is just press the
button and you might be able to hear the
fair noise
when you're breathing in and out
why is this because i'm a hebrew
breather and all we need to do is just
press for about two seconds until we
hear two beeps
there we go
so this is the voice on feature
now
it's definitely not more clear right do
you know you can definitely
now you do hear a little bit of like
audio peaking when it comes to the
microphone it's as good as it gets for
me as long as i can conversate with my
fellow colleagues and my friends
then this
works and i love it fact i don't sound
like ben anymore i sound like sean
connery
burned james bond
so yes obviously a lot more clearer and
amplified by that means now of course
it's not gonna sound all natural but can
it be improved
yes of course
but
look
to fit a speaker and a microphone in
this face mask
simply brilliant
this
is a huge plus
for lg
now for those of you who have owned the
first generation you're probably
wondering to yourselves
well the second generation worked with
the first generation case now for those
who don't know the case not only
provides storage
for your mask but it also has two
functions a drying function and a uv ray
function to keep it all nice and
hygienic will the second generation mask
fit
and work
clearly not meant to be designed that
way now we have contacted lg and they
said that they will be rolling out its
own dedicated case for the second gen
mask so do look out for that now for
those who are planning to own one of
these for yourself the second gen
wearable air purifier of course is that
lg is planning to roll out its own
dedicated app where you're able to track
all the data that you need
for this mask you will be able to check
your battery levels and it will remind
you when to replace your filters on top
of that you have full control of the
mask from turning it on and off changing
the fan speeds turning on the voice on
feature and check on your respiratory
data so overall lg has created a cool
piece of tech and i'm really loving the
second generation
wearable air purifier and with that it
comes down to the cost of these things
compared to a regular disposable mask
this of course comes at a premium price
of 249 singapore dollars
is it a tad overkill for some
yes maybe
but for those of you who are concerned
about protecting yourselves and your
family members
heck even those who are interested in
doing all the tech wear kind of outfits
there's a black version
i bet you didn't know about that
so be it against allergens pollutants
and even myself i'm when it comes to
pollen season pour my sinuses acts up
oh man or you just want really good
filtered air then this is something you
want to consider so those are my
thoughts on the lg pre-k wearable air
purifier 2.0
if you have any questions let us know
down in the comments below and if you're
looking to get one for yourselves anyone
more details on it check out the link in
the description below as well
so all you need to do is like and
subscribe guys subscribe
if you need the subscribers guys
till then
this is your boy zacky
signing off
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
you